Greymon went to set the screen down to
three look how far they push the Mary
down the lane for the way
they got a mismatch
the settle furs over here know what he
knows he could get by a bigger man
overextending was Harold too much
precious curry just used that pressure
against montrezl harrell and beat him to
the basket the other thing is if you
stick a jumper with seven seconds left
or something
the Clippers live an opportunity step
fled the clock is 0.5 he knew what he
was doing Bobby that tip crap minor
kitchen comes in ahead a little lower
into the paint turns swings it to Aminu
makes a tremendous catch back to
daybreak reels in a three look at the
turnover because of the hands to ammo
the deflection and this is this is
controlled chaos in extent but the
Pacers trying to rush and get a shot and
dame ends up with it in the corner what
what a deflection from oh and in Dame
saying I didn't forget about all that
nonsense that took place in the first
half
Green riding him to the baseline got in
the ear that's a great place the play
from Chima was it to get that mom that
thing down I've ever done and doing it a
goal then leads the NBA in steals here's
curry
[Music]
a chance to send the Thunder home
Willard long-range three
[Applause]
he points on that with that's amazing
five years ago
against your rocket yes
when the first round series
[Applause]
for 50 points
goodnight Oklahoma City sees it over
why says with the left hand
hurry three-quarter court
beats the buzzer with a Benton 3 for his
first triple of the quarter not worrying
about his staff I'm gives himself a
chance
in set by Lillard into the paint seven
to shoot for Damian Lillard fires from
[Applause]
look out the Damian is towards nowhere
close left open by Steph Curry white
jerseys came up with it somehow has the
presence of mind to see Jonas Jerebko
they hope can fulfill that stretch for
when you get a pass with that much space
Blazers at all two ends one you guys for
those that go to the that should bring
in Zach colleges that flying Joe and
shot and got hit in the head too could
have been an n1
if you fear to get yes
[Applause]
it has to fade away with CJ right up in
his visit off it comes Dan cuts between
defenders comes in with a hammer blow on
a right hand jam to put the Blazers on
top I want and Damian Lillard just get
in the war
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
four-point play
but who hit sell and they watch Markieff
Morris well then oh boy you're right
because Bradley Beal came right under
Stephon curry the hardest player to
guard it might be him one on one
his he can get to whatever shot he wants
same way outside from the a in arena
stop the triple that much over the last
three games there is st. eating it up
[Applause]
[Music]
tip away but like you said quality gotta
get a quality shot damn outside of three
[Music]
between defenders spring strip 3 and he
hates to the
it happened when Avery Bradley was in
the game he tailed the officials about
it
by hollis-jefferson dream on saving it
step hiding behind Jordan and there's
the record nobody's ever made five or
more threes and seven games in a row
nobody's ever made five or more threes
in seven straight until right there you
can say the boys have two timeouts
Denver - Damian goes to work has to get
it going takes it to the rim shot out of
a cannon right to the rim is the shot or
the dunk I should say from gaming right
over the top of Millsap perhaps looking
for step
turns and fires a three
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
women taking it home but he felt LeBron
James needed some of these veterans like
Chandler and Stevenson and Rondo around
La Paz rough curry and Iguodala finishes
with the Warriors to eight points here
in the fourth quarter which with by far
be a season low
Lillard from deep it's over see Woody
Hayes game I think at that level Unni
knew it
[Applause]
his passing can be equally entertaining
[Music]
got the ball right now stride the
three-point arc would sell to shoot
Jamie it would take a [ __ ] his right
half white drives into the lane draws
the bump countered if it goes it does
little backhand scoop Sean show the
Pythons how do you do this to break
through the two and then still locate
the rim put that ball love with the
inside hand offense their 16th in the
league and efficient defensive
efficiency curry curry from Steph Curry
so select Acula finish and the crazy
thing about it these are shots he works
on it's not by accident
he works on these shots five to shoot
Lillard add is a bomb
which husband oozing out of his baby
that's in the NBA at it you give him a
little space he will make you pay when
it comes to this league behind the back
floater over some bonus to back it in
couple stepping curry what a sequence
the weak side defender rotates and the
feathery skill to drop it in Westbrook
from behind the arc is now our four he
is 3 for 15 shooting in this game
[Applause]
thirty puddings in this series already
comes curry here's a long one Jenny -
down to one his three two and a half and
he got it Stefan curry nine of ten
twenty three points bending should know
that he's going to take this as the
clock winds down to the halftime break
that is what he does
long ball by dame coming up with Felton
autumn lifts off so a step-back three
pointer is up
there is a 3-2
[Music]
curry fakes all rankles a past I think
it's not the woman point nine remaining
plays on the offensive end Steph Curry
taking the double-team finding a wide
open Andre Iguodala of Game three and
then answered with 15 in the third
quarter he in Game four so here's
Lillard gets up the first took going you
know a lot of that first half scoring
was with McCollum on the bench who had
three fouls and Lillard to the shot
curry fakes two BOTS trying to stay with
him curry there it is the first few no
get down in there at six three on board
for Willard
it's been all along with anticipation
though by hours all knocked into the
backcourt Lillard keeps it himself
fires it off
it's still tame time and you want to get
your little brother in this rubble and
you throw this off ballot Russell what's
the cross-court
[Music]
[Applause]
this is how the rest of the leaders
waving off start but after a missed free
throw Millard now free crowd oohs as his
course over got McKinney to fall
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
he's got five across midcourt with four
dribbling between the cones with two to
land up and in
did you see him switch gears I was watch
him he's taking his time he knows how
much time is on the clock he's not in
any hurry right now and watch behind the
screen Julie just switches it into a
whole nother gear
I'm gonna tell you right now that's
that's the play of the game optician of
the quarter high-risk high-reward
seven to shoot Lillard polls polls
Connelly upon him he sends in at
three-point shot
oh man he was in the freezer and then
popped out with a cape on he's under
wraps locked up in the freezer no
Superman can get outside put that cape
on
[Music]
[Applause]
24-second violation but Steph are the
other needed couple trees there's one my
goodness now you got a foul rebound grab
I have it here he comes with four Dame
races ahead
[Applause]
intensive a second left a lot of space
to work with
after the Miss you got five seconds what
can you do with it
now four seconds left you need to do it
again
hurry for three think that Wow and then
go to double overtime Oh her is really
clearly there's one left he is pointing
him a lot you can let's grab him after
his dribbling the balls on the floor
like that and instead curry stripes of
three oh what a clutch shot they got a
very poor whistle on the Durant three
this part of the official there fifteen
attempts check that then that was their
foul to get there so no free throws
Lillard with two hits to the basket and
scores with a 10 to the second left and
a half he's got this right here by step
in traffic not even really looking at
Katie yeah a great first quarter and
then hog on
here's Lillard with the shot clock tower
gets a clean
look at this Lillard pulls up the clocks
going down he had to force the head up
in him
Turner darn encourage her up go sets the
screen carry long distance way outside
puts it in Steph Curry from downtown see
Steph Curry comes off that screen big
guy sitting further back you make them
pay the price what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content